[Music]
it's over a thousand miles long the
frozen border between ukraine and russia
is divided by trenches and in places a
thin metal fence and berm
the right hand side is russia
a few miles away across freezing fields
and drifting snow thousands of russian
soldiers tanks and missile systems are
waiting for orders
ukrainian border patrol says they
continuously monitor russian movements
towards them
on the face of it they seem fairly
unfazed by the prospect
of
[Music]
as we film near the fence a russian
border patrol passed nearby
the two sides are that close
we put it in puts it in perspective how
close we are to russia because that is
the russian border security
uh patrolling um we've been with the
ukrainian side and there they are
and both sides right next to each other
as you can see
you didn't expect to see them i have to
be honest
but uh the ukrainians say that they do
the same job as them
and they do see each other quite often
of course not with the sort of
underlying tension uh that uh the world
is seeing right now
and that tension deepened here in the
regional capital
when ukraine's president said he thought
that this country's second city could
well be targeted by president putin if
he decides to invade
young professionals like victor and
julia say they like all their friends
are genuinely scared now
yulia has volunteered to become a
battlefield medic
like on the edge
of something very terrible
and scaring so
yes
i i can say
kind of scared
you know russians living by a war but by
their huge imperial ambitions but
ukrainians
agree with victory very peaceful nation
but in case if someone tries to took our
freedom again we will fight back
quite what a full-scale invasion would
look like isn't known russian tanks
could come straight across these frozen
farmlands
what's equally unknown is for how long
the ukrainian army can resist
stuart ramsey sky news eastern ukraine
you